yes sir what is probably the most epic
World Championship ever Fischer Spassky
electrifies the planet can you imagine
and you know well because I live this is
when you lived it our World Championship
chess match that the whole the whole
world is watching stopped and stopped
and watched 1972 Bobby Fischer Boris
Spassky nobody saw coming
not the Icelanders not the fidei not the
US Chess Federation nobody expected this
match this World Chess Championship
match to go from piddling nothing puddle
to big-time money and front-page news
that's exactly what happened Murray's
1969 Fischer Spassky world championship
10,000 rubles prize funds he's looking
petrosian's basket Petrosyan Spassky
sorry 69 10 thousand rubles Bobby
Fischer Boris Spassky two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars which at the time
was real money real money that just was
a quantum leap and it was because of
Bobby Fischer and who he was and what
was Bobby Fischer Bobby Fischer was
another one of these forces of nature
that isn't possible to control and deal
with the best thing you can do is just
go with the flow and when he let him you
can't let him carry you
I remember reading when he had beaten
burn in that game of the century when
he's a teenager
13 years just just incredible
sacrificial game yeah the Soviets said
oh yeah it's just boy in America we're
gonna have to pay some attention that's
right leap forward those years he showed
his stuff in those years but he he was a
little unbalanced I mean he was quitting
he didn't play in some of the
tournaments that would have got making
them a chance earlier and he never had
defeated Spassky that's right man
absolutely which is incredible that he
managed to dominate the way he did yeah
absolutely so prior to 1972 Bobby
Fischer played five times against Boris
Spassky and lost dream drawn to so he'd
never tasted blood at least Boris
passkeys blood now at the same time that
he could not puncture Boris Spassky he's
beating the best players in the world
six zips except knives killer we're
talking about Stein it's when you know
like these guys won back and forth back
and forth
but as chess got so refined such great
understanding there were so many drawers
epic epic drawing contest trying bouts
this guy's beating the world's best
player six zero and capturing the
imagination of the world well you're
talking about beating Larsen you're
talking might be an entire man robbed
then they threw the treasures from the
rumor that I heard Kitsch coroner was
supposed to play him but he let
Petrosian go ahead you're gonna have a
better change yeah you're right
bad come get some that's right now he
plays bass key and the whole world is
paying attention to this man
exactly Kissinger Secretary of State
that's right of the United States right
calling out Fischer saying go beat those
Soviets for us exactly I mean giving him
that extra thing so for me as a kid I'm
a middle-class family we watched the
night leading news Walter Cronkite man
he's my guy to give me a glimpse of the
world this is Walter Cronkite and he
come on and he said hello everybody I in
the news today and he go through you
know the top things you know
President Nixon did this something else
happened over here something I like but
now before we get into our new segments
let's go over to our correspondent and
rekha Vick Iceland to see how Bobby
Fischer played his match with Boris
basking there's like what you're gonna
stop the nightly news to go and check in
on the chess match that nobody paid
attention to before suddenly Bobby
Fischer had created a
a news frenzy that unless you actually
lived it and saw it
you think it's it's it's unimaginable
today it's incredible for from me who I
wasn't into chess
all right at the time reading about it
and also the idea that Fischer was also
the master psychologist himself I'm not
sure if he did it on purpose just to
create all that turmoil but the way he
took on h2 in the first game which was
completely ridiculous loses the game
then says that's it I'm not playing for
her second game how does he win that
match right he must have rattled Spassky
beyond me right when you talk about
Fischer the psychologist I think of a
Muhammad Ali Mohammed Ali played mind
games with disappointment but
purposefully and he'd let you know and
everybody who's ever followed pugilists
sports knows that a man I'm gonna murder
to bum you know but even while he was
playing those obvious and shallow mind
games he was playing deeper mind games
was Muhammad Ali and and in the bouts
the guys were rattled and I think I
genuinely do believe that Bobby Fischer
whether it was intentional or not
rattled his opponents before they even
got to the table there was a nervousness
and he had that active disdain almost it
seemed yeah he made it clear he didn't
like the Soviets right I thought they
were cheaters Russians were chow yeah I
grudge absolutely sure and to him
this was person right and the whole
Soviet Machine rise against them was
preparing for him and it felt like the
lone American maverick right was going
against this guy in the middle of the
Cold War exactly when the US and Soviets
were not friendly in any way shape or
form right just incredible that he was
able to take them down and just remember
that the entirety of the whole world ran
on a single philosophy called mad ma D
which stood for mutually assured
destruction the only reason we didn't go
war with one another is because we were
mutually assured we will destroy one
another so when you talk about the Cold
War
well the chess battle was just the model
of the real world who knew but it was
art imitates life life imitates art and
Bobby Fischer love him or hate him
because a lot of people hated him you
know as well right
captured the imagination of the world he
really did he took chess to another
level
totally attention and resources he has
definitely left his mark on history and
continues to be talked about as one of
the great champions in the game
absolutely